hello and welcome to maths in play fire
as we are all aware a global pandemic is
underway and it's affecting millions
worldwide everywhere around us we hear
the words pandemic and epidemic what do
these words mean we'll try to understand
these terms one by one and see how
relevant they are in our current
scenario the Atlanta Center for Disease
Control defines an epidemic as the
occurrence of more cases of disease
injury or other health conditions than
expected in a given area or among a
specific group of persons during a
particular period usually the cases are
presumed to have a common cause or to be
related to one another in some way in
simple words an epidemic is the rapid
spread of a disease to a large number of
people in a given population within a
very short period of time the important
points to pay attention in this
definition are rapidly spreading disease
which involves a large number of people
and in a short period of time the word
itself traces its origin from Greek
words epi meaning upon endemic which
comes from the word Deimos which means
people when an epidemic has spread
across a large region for example
multiple continents it is called a
pandemic
although it's very difficult to explain
the exact mechanism of how and when
epidemics start we can broadly divide
them into three main types common source
epidemics propagated epidemics and mixed
type epidemics
in a common source epidemic a group of
people get infected from a common source
of infection for example suppose a bunch
of people ate at a restaurant and the
food of that restaurant was infected
with staph bacteria toxin note that food
poisonings are not caused by the
bacteria itself rather the toxin that is
produced by this bacteria the bacteria
itself gets destroyed by the cooking
process now all these people developed
food poisoning and this is an example of
common source epidemic these infected
people cannot transmit the infection
further to more people as a food
poisoning was caused by a toxin in the
food and nor the actual bacteria itself
this is important as our next type of
epidemic the propagated epidemic differs
in exactly this point only in a
propagated epidemic a similar scenario
can occur a group of people went to a
restaurant and rather than getting
infected by eating contaminated food
suppose they all get a virus from the
person who was serving the food to all
these people
now the basic difference between common
source and propagated epidemic is that
in the case of a propagated epidemic
these infected people can further infect
more people one infected human transmits
of virus to another healthy human and so
on in this manner the number of cases
grow exponentially within a few weeks
and this is why it is known as a
propagated epidemic
mixed outbreak epidemics have
characteristics of both common source
and propagated outbreaks
so this was about how epidemics start
and how they propagate and that is what
makes an epidemic so dangerous is
ability to affect more and more people
as a time progresses and that brings us
to our next important question which is
how do epidemic spread from one person
to another when there are numerous ways
a disease can spread some of the most
common ways are airborne transmission
arthropod transmission contact
transmission and fecal oral transmission
airborne transmission is the spread of
infection by droplet nuclei or dust in
the air whenever an infected person
coughs or sneezes small droplets of
water are released in the air these
small particles contain millions of
viral particles these water particles
are known as droplets if they are more
than 5 micrometers in diameter and
droplet nuclei if they are less than 5
micrometers in diameter droplets which
are larger in diameter fall rapidly to
the ground under the influence of
gravity and therefore are transmitted
only over a limited distance of less
than 1 meters droplet nuclei on the
other hand are less than 5 micrometers
in diameter and hence can remain
suspended in the air for significant
periods of time and can be transmitted
over distances greater than 1 meter
these droplet nuclei are then inhaled by
another person which gets infected by
the virus arthropod transmission takes
place by an insect
for example the malaria epidemic which
was spread by mosquitoes
contact transmission is the mode of
transmission when the infection spreads
from one person to another by mode of
touch in the fecal-oral transmission the
infectious agent is shared by the
infected host in feces and acquired by
the susceptible host through ingestion
of contaminated food and water it's
important to know that not all people
who get infected in an epidemic get sick
and they can sometimes still pass on the
infection to other people however people
who have immunity are able to resist
infections to know more about immunity
and how it protects you from infections
and diseases watch our video series on
the structure of immunity and how to
strengthen your immunity naturally
all of us are aware of the global crisis
we are facing today you may be hearing
statements like your country is in stage
two of the pandemic or stage three of
the pandemic
what are these stages and numbers what
does it tell us well WH o closely
studied previous epidemics and classify
the progression of epidemics into five
main stages according to wh o the stage
one consists of predominantly animal
infections and a few human infections
Stage two is said to have reached when
there is sustained human to human
transmission and stage three is when
widespread human infection is seen in
the form of whole communities being
involved this is the pandemic stage
where the number of cases are
exponentially increasing Stage four is
the post peak stage which signifies that
the pandemic activity appears to be
decreasing Stage five or the post
pandemic phase is said to have reached
when the disease activity level reaches
the level of seasonal flu at this stage
it is important to maintain surveillance
and be prepared for future epidemics
epidemics have been a part of human
history since the beginning of time from
Blake to cholera to HIV to the current
scenario millions have suffered
recovered or tied kindly follow your
local guidelines and stay safe